YOU CAN'T MAKE THIS UP.
IT'S LIKE IT WRITES ITSELF EVERY
NIGHT.
BUCKIN
BUCKLE UP.
SUBPOENAS, THREATS OF CONTEMPT.
CALLS FOR IMPEACHMENT AND
OBSESSIVE HYSTERIA OVER DECADES
OLD TAX DOCUMENTS THAT REVEAL
NOTHING NEW AND ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING ILLEGAL.
AND THE MEDIA'S GOING NUTS
AGAIN.
OH, THAT'S RIGHT.
BECAUSE MUELLER DIDN'T COME OUT
THE WAY THEY WANT, LET'S MOVE
ONTO THE NEXT CONSPIRACY
THEORIES.
MAYBE HILLARY CLINTON COLLUDED
WITH CHINA.
THERE THEY ARE IN THE "NEW YORK
TIMES."
I KNOW FACTS ARE HARD THINGS FOR
SOME PEOPLE ON THE LEFT AND THE
MEDIA MOB TO UNDERSTAND.
TRUMP'S STILL A BILLIONAIRE.
YEAH, HE'S STILL PRESIDENT.
WE ALL KNEW THAT WHAT HAPPENED
IN NEW JERSEY IN THE CASINO
BUSINESS, YEAH, IT KIND OF WENT
SOUTH.
BUSINESSES FAIL EVERY DAY.
THE TRUMP ORGANIZATION IS STILL
AN OVERWHELMING AMERICAN SUCCESS
STORY.
BUT THIS KIND OF VITRIOL JUST
REPRESENTS WHAT THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY HAS BECOME.
WE'RE GOING TO GET THAT FOR THE
NEXT TWO YEARS.
WE NEED TAX EXPERTS!
THIS IS A POLITICAL THING FILLED
WITH SORE LOSERS THAT ARE NOW
BORDERING ON RAGE PSYCHOSIS THAT
COULDN'T ACCEPT THE RESULTS OF
THE 2016 ELECTION.
NOW REFUSING TO ACCEPT THE
RESULTS OF MUELLER'S
INVESTIGATION, AND NOW MORE ON
HINGE THAN EVER.
AFTER BEING COOPERATIVE IN A
BROAD 22-MONTH WITCH HUNT, THE
PRESIDENT IS RIGHTLY SAYING
ENOUGH IS ENOUGH AND HE'S
PUTTING HIS FOOT DOWN.
HE DIDN'T SAY OR USE EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE ONE TIME.
HE ALLOWED EVERYBODY IN THE
WHITE HOUSE TO TALK TO THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL.
1.5 MILLION DOCUMENTS.
THIS WEEK, THE WHITE HOUSE DID
ORDER, FINALLY FIGHTING BACK,
FORMER COUNSEL DON McGAHN WITH A
NOT TO COMPLY ORDER AS IT
RELATES TO THE CONGRESSIONAL
SUBPOENA.
HE WAS ALREADY INTERVIEWED BY
ROBERT MUELLER FOR A WHOPPING 30
HOURS.
THE GUY IS TALKED OUT.
HE HAS NOTHING LEFT TO SAY.
MEANWHILE, ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR
IS REFUSING TO RELEASE THE FULL
UNREDACTED VERSION OF THE
MUELLER REPORT BECAUSE HE'S
ACTUALLY FOLLOWING THE LAW AND
BECAUSE THE LAW WAS PASSED BY
DEMOCRATS.
BARR, BY THE WAY, WAS NOT
REQUIRED TO RELEASE ONE SINGLE
LETTER, NO WORD, NO PHRASE,
NOTHING OF THE MUELLER REPORT.
AND THE ONLY REDACTIONS TO THE
FULL REPORT INCLUDE, OH, GRAND
JURY INFORMATION, LANGUAGE
PERTAINING TO ONGOING CASES,
INVESTIGATORY SOURCES AND
METHODS.
CAN'T LET THAT OUT ANYWAY.
AND ACCORDING TO PRESS SECRETARY
SARAH SANDERS, THE WHITE HOUSE
MIGHT ORDER THE DOJ TO BLOCK
ROBERT MUELLER FROM TESTIFYING
ON THE HILL.
I HAVE A LOT OF QUESTIONS FOR
MUELLER.
WHY DID HE APPOINT ANDREW
WISEMAN AND A BAND OF DEMOCRATS,
PEOPLE THAT WITHHELD EXCULPATORY
EVIDENCE IN THE PAST AND PEOPLE
THAT REPRESENTED HILLARY
CLINTON.
I'D LIKE A FEW OF THOSE
QUESTIONS.
WHY DID ROBERT MUELLER NOT TOUCH
HILLARY CLINTON'S BOUGHT AND
PAID FOR DIRTY RUSSIAN DOSSIER?
I KNOW HE WAS BUSY.
HE WAS LOOKING INTO FARA
VIOLATIONS, THE BAD LOAN
APPLICATIONS, INCOMPLETE TAX
RETURNS, TAXI MEDALLIONS.
TOO BUSY TO INVESTIGATE
HILLARY'S BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
RUSSIAN LIES AND PROPAGANDA TO
IMPACT THE 2016 ELECTION WHICH
WAS PART OF THE MANDATE OF WHAT
HE WAS SUPPOSED TO BE DOING.
WATCH THIS.
>> SHOULD WE TAKE THE
PRESIDENT'S TWEET FROM THIS PAST
WEEKEND AS AN ORDER TO BILL BARR
TO NOT ALLOW ROBERT MUELLER TO
TESTIFY?
>> I THINK THAT'S A
DETERMINATION TO BE MADE AT THIS
POINT.
I THINK --
>> TO HIS CREDIT, THOUGH --
>> THAT'S THE PRESIDENT'S
FEELINGS ON THE MATTER.
THE REASON IS BECAUSE WE
CONSIDER THIS AS A CASE CLOSED.
AS A FINISHED PROCESS.
AND, AGAIN, I THINK MOST
AMERICANS THINK THAT THIS IS
FINISHED.
>> Sean: MOST AMERICANS DO.
SANDERS IS RIGHT.
IT'S OVER.
IT'S DONE.
FROM NOW ON, IT'S ONLY NOISE.
TWO AND A HALF YEARS, DEMOCRATS,
MEDIA MOB, JAMES COMEY AND THE
DEEP STATE TRYING TO RIP THIS
COUNTRY APART OVER A HOAX, A
CONSPIRACY THEORY WITH NO
EVIDENCE AND ONLY ANONYMOUS
SOURCES.
EVEN LEADER McCONNELL PUT IT
THIS WAY, THEY WERE HOPING FOR A
NATIONAL CRISIS FOR POLITICAL
GAIN.
THAT'S SO PATRIOTIC OF THEM,
ISN'T IT?
TAKE A LOOK.
>> IT'S BEEN TWO WEEKS SINCE
ATTORNEY GENERAL WILLIAM BARR
MADE THE 450-PAGE REPORT PUBLIC.
THIS INVESTIGATION WENT ON FOR
TWO YEARS.
IT'S FINALLY OVER.
THEY TOLD EVERYONE THERE HAD
BEEN A CONSPIRACY BETWEEN RUSSIA
AND THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
YET ON THIS CENTRAL QUESTION,
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL'S FINDING IS
CLEAR.
CASE CLOSED.
>> Sean: NOW, THE SENATOR IS
LAYING OUT FACTS.
DEMOCRATS COULD NOT BE MORE
DETACHED FROM TRUTH, REALITY.
LET'S LOOK AT SPEAKER PELOSI.
SHE'S NOT REALLY SPEAKER.
SHE'S SPEAKER IN NAME ONLY.
IT'S SPEAKER OCASIO-CORTEZ AND
SPEAKER IN NAME ONLY PELOSI.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE FLOOR OF THE SENATE,
SENATOR McCONNELL IS REPORTED TO
BE SAYING DOESN'T MATTER HEAR
FROM MUELLER, CASE CLOSED.
CASE CLOSED.
I DON'T THINK SO.
JUST AS A MATTER OF OBSERVATION,
THAT'S JUST NOT A FACT.
THE CASE IS NOT CLOSED.
>> Sean: SHE MAY WANT TO CHECK
IN WITH SPEAKER OCASIO-CORTEZ
BECAUSE THE CASE IS CLOSED.
PELOSI WENT ONTO DECLARE THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS GOADING HER
INTO IMPEACHMENT.
THAT'S WHAT HE'S DOING.
YOU FIGURED IT OUT.
ANOTHER CONSPIRACY THEORY.
JUST WHEN YOU THINK THEY'RE DONE
WITH CONSPIRACY THEORIES AND
LYING.
THESE PEOPLE ARE AMAZING.
THEY SHOULD WRITE MOVIES.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> TRUMP IS GOADING US TO
IMPEACH HIM.
THAT'S WHAT HE'S DOING.
EVERY SINGLE DAY HE'S JUST LIKE
TAUNTING, TAUNTING, TAUNTING
BECAUSE HE KNOWS THAT IT WOULD
BE VERY DIVISIVE IN THE COUNTRY
BUT HE DOESN'T REALLY CARE.
JUST WANTS TO SOLIDIFY HIS BASE.
>> FOR PELOSI AND HER DEMOCRATIC
COLLEAGUES AND THE MEDIA MOB,
IT'S NOT ABOUT IN ANY WAY
TALKING ABOUT OR LEGISLATING OR
IMPROVING THE LIVES OF YOU, WE,
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, BETTERING
THE ECONOMY, MAKING THE WORLD A
BETTER PLACE, MORE SAFE, MORE
SECURE, MORE PROSPEROUS.
IT'S ALWAYS ABOUT SCORING CHEAP
POLITICAL POINTS WITH THEIR
RADICAL BASE.
57% OF DEMOCRATS BELIEVE
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS GUILTY OF
TREASON.
THEY'VE BEEN LIED TO EVERY
SECOND, EVERY MINUTE, EVERY HOUR
OF EVERY DAY ON EVERY NEWS
CHANNEL EXCEPT PRIME TIME HERE.
WHAT DO YOU EXPECT?
OF COURSE THEY'RE GOING TO
BELIEVE THAT LIE.
ACCORDING TO MULTIPLE SURVEYS,
VAST MAJORITY OF DEMOCRATS --
AMERICANS, THOUGH, THEY'RE
AGAINST IMPEACHMENT.
WITHOUT A DOUBT, THE FAR LEFT,
DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST PARTY, THEY
ARE OUT OF TOUCH WITH TRUTH AND
REALITY AND CAN NO LONGER ACCEPT
BASIC FUNDAMENTAL TRUTHS.
SAME REASON WHY SO MANY TRUMP
HATERS ARE REFUSING TO ADMIT A
SIMPLE DISTURBING TRUTH AS WELL.
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN WAS SPIED ON.
IT HAPPENED.
IT'S NOT A QUESTION OF WHETHER
SPYING TOOK PLACE.
QUESTION IS, HOW MUCH SPYING AND
BY HOW MANY PEOPLE.
NOW, EVEN FORMER NATIONAL INTEL
DIRECTOR TURN FAKE NEWS CNN HACK
JAMES CLAPPER ADMITS THIS SIMPLE
TRUTH, LOOKS LIKE SPYING TO ME.
WELL, IT WAS SPYING.
TAKE A LOOK.
THERE ARE PROTOCOLS AND
STANDARDS FOR USING AN AGENT,
AND I'M SURE THAT'S THE CASE
HERE.
>> YOU'RE SAYING THIS WAS NOT
DONE LIGHTLY.
>> NO, IT'S NEVER DONE LIGHTLY.
>> WAS IT SPYING?
>> WELL, YEAH, I GUESS IT MEETS
THE DICTIONARY DEFINITION OF --
OF SURVEILLANCE OR SPYING.
>> Sean: UH-HUH.
YEAH.
WHEN OUR FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
SENDS IN UNDERCOVER AGENTS, OH,
LIKE A HOT BLONDE BOMBSHELL
THAT'S REALLY FLIRTACIOUS AND
MAKES HERSELF AVAILABLE TO
GEORGE PAPADOPOULOS FOR THE
PURPOSE OF EXTRACTING
INFORMATION FROM HIM, THAT'S
SPYING.
THEY TRAPPED THEM INTO SAYING
THINGS THEY CAN'T SAY BECAUSE
THEY DON'T KNOW, THAT WOULD BE
SPYING.
WHEN CARTER PAGE -- HE'S GOING
TO JOIN US IN A MOMENT -- HAD
HIS CALLS AND E-MAILS TAPPED BY
OUR OWN FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AFTER
THEY COMMITTED A MASSIVE FISA
FRAUD WITH THE BULK OF THE
APPLICATION AND INFORMATION
BEING HILLARY'S DOSSIER, THAT
WAS SPYING.
THE BASIS FOR THAT SPYING WAS
HILLARY AND HER DIRTY RUSSIAN
DOSSIER.
HE TOP OF A FISA WARRANT -- I
JUST LEARNED THIS TODAY -- IT
SAYS VERIFIED.
IT WAS NEVER VERIFIED.
IT'S UNVERIFIABLE.
THIS DOCUMENT TOTALLY
UNVERIFIED.
"NEW YORK TIMES" EVEN SUGGESTING
ALL OF IT, PAID FOR BY HILLARY,
MAY HAVE BEEN RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION FROM THE GET-GO.
WE HAVE ONE MORE PIECE OF
DAMNING EVIDENCE THAT THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION KNEW THAT THE
DOSSIER WAS A FRAUDULENT
POLITICAL HACK JOB WELL BEFORE
COMEY USED IT, AND THEY USED IT
FOR THE BASIS OF THE FISA
APPLICATION.
ACCORDING TO JOHN SOLOMON, TEN
DAYS BEFORE THAT FIRST FISA
REQUEST, THE AUTHOR OF THAT
DOSSIER CONFESSED TO THE DEPUTY
ASSISTANT SECRETARY OF STATE
"HIS RESEARCH WAS POLITICAL AND
FACING AN ELECTION DAY
DEADLINE."
STATE DEPARTMENT MEMORIALIZED
THIS CONVERSATION IN A WRITTEN
STATEMENT SUBSEQUENTLY HIDDEN
FROM CONGRESSMAN DEVIN NUNES
DURING HIS HOUSE INTEL
INVESTIGATION.
THE SHOCKING REVELATION SHINING
LIGHT ON A SERIES OF TEXTS